früher sagte man ja katholische kirche
und war sünden begangen und du zahlst
ablas und bist frei von sünde
heute würde man sagen willst grün bist
du frei von sünde stellen wir alle sind
jetzt für klimaschutz ja das problem ist
nur jetzt müsste man beginnen werden sie
klimaschutz woanders klimaschutz später
klimaschutz mit wasserstoff in zehn
jahren das hilft mir heute nicht
[Musik]
lassen sie uns über die politischen
konsequenzen sprechen herr lindner cdu
kanzlerkandidat laschet der mit ihnen
der fdp in nordrhein westfalen regiert
hat gesagt weil jetzt ein solcher tag
ist ändert man nicht die politik sehen
sie das auch so nein das sehe ich nicht
so
sondern na ja auch vor diesem ereignis
hat meine partei die fdp auf eine andere
klimapolitik in deutschland gedrungen
eine die wirksam die ziele erreicht und
deshalb auf andere mittel setzt
wir haben ja seit einigen jahren eine
politik die wie ich es empfinde sehr
stark bürokratisch orientiert ist sehr
stark einzel entscheidungen trifft und
deshalb die ziele nicht erreicht
aber ich meinte ich mache ja ob dieser
moment so ein bisschen ist wie fukushima
dass man das gefühl hat ist ein
einschnitt eine zäsur
und wir müssen jetzt politik neu denken
oder irgendwas an maßnahmen verschärfen
ist das für sie so ein fukushima moment
gewesen dass aprilia verbunden ich war
mit der deutschen klimapolitik bereits
vor diesem ereignis nicht einverstanden
und zufrieden weil ich glaube dass wir
an zwei stellen zugleich neu denken
müssen
zum einen haben wir eine klimapolitik
die aus den von mir gerade nur kurz
angedeuteten gründen nicht wirksam die
ziele erreicht das ist ja die bilanz der
letzten jahre dass wir oft ehrgeizige
ambitionierte ziele haben die regelmäßig
verschärft werden die aber dann auf dem
papier stehen bleiben und nicht in der
praxis erreicht werden und wir haben auf
der anderen seite nicht erkannt dass
nach meiner überzeugung der globale
klimaschutz
das nächste wachstums fortschritts und
investitions thema für die ganze welt
sein kann haben wir nicht erkannt wir
führen kleinteilige diskussion und
deshalb wünsche ich mir einen doppelten
neustart in deutschland wirksame
klimapolitik und zugleich den deutschen
klimaschutz als den klimaschutz einer
nation von technikerinnen und
ingenieuren zu einem weltweiten export
thema zu machen denn
die chinesen wollen bis 2030 noch
zusätzlich co2 ausstoßen zwar noch mehr
jedes jahr da steigt noch an
das zeigt ja wenn wir in deutschland
jetzt technologische lösungen finden die
wirtschaftlichen fortschritt und
freiheitliche lebensweise verbindet mit
ressourcenschonung dann leisten wir
einen beitrag wirklich in globaler
verantwortung
jim ist mir dann klingt das so wir haben
eigentlich ideen wir haben pläne wir
haben auch lösungen gefühlt dauert das
aber alles sehr lange sagen sie denn
nach diesem ereignis und die eifel ist
uns näher als japan
da muss jetzt mehr tempo mehr
radikalität auch wir bei den grünen
müssen jetzt noch mal irgendwie das ein
oder andere oben drauf packen oder
machen jetzt einfach so weiter es ist ja
shit muss mir die fairness halber sagen
jedoch schon das gegenteil gesagt das
hängt glaube ich immer so ein bisschen
von der tagesform ab was er zum
klimaschutz sagt und ich bin beeindruckt
lindner wir kennen uns ja schon ne weile
das flammende plädoyer für den
klimaschutz ich kann mich noch an zeiten
erinnern da haben sie uns erklärt kann
man alles nachlesen und googeln
deutschland ein prozent der
weltbevölkerung übrigens zwei prozent
des co2 ausstoßes wenn wir die alten co2
emissionen da zur echten sogar nochmal
deutlich mehr macht doch den kohl nicht
fett der rest der welt wohl vorangehen
dann haben sie uns lange erklärt wir
haben nicht so und da mal zusammen
vorhanden lassen
wir haben mal zusammen verhandelt kann
man das ist ja keine so europäisch naja
also das kann man glaube ich belegen
machen sie bitte den faktencheck wollen
doch nicht alle sind jetzt für
klimaschutz das problem ist nur jetzt
müsste man beginnen will sie klimaschutz
woanders klimaschutz später klimaschutz
mit wasserstoff in zehn jahren das hilft
mir heute nicht erst einen gewissen
aussteigen oder zum fossilen verbrenner
heute müssen wir aussteigen aus der
kohleverstromung wollte müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass co2 preis bekommt jeden
dieser vorschläge lehnen sie ab deshalb
kommen wir nicht weiter und darum wird
es zeit dass die nächste bundesregierung
sie hat
ein bisschen vorgelegt die sendung heißt
ja für und wieder hört sich schon mal
ganz gut an aber wir haben ja auch das
publikum hier mit zwei seiten wollen mal
auf diese seite gehen das ist die seite
die sagen wir brauchen wirklich eine
radikale klimawende und ich möchte hier
eine aktivistin von feile ist für future
begrüßen charisma guten abend schön dass
sie da sind
hier habe ich schon ein bisschen was
gehört habe ich möchte sie nach nach den
grünen fragen herr ist mir hat ja auch
schon ein bisschen vorgelegt reicht
ihnen das was die grünen jetzt in sachen
klima wende davor haben nein wir haben
stand heute und das ist eines der
fundamentalen probleme dieses
wahlkampfes keine einzige partei die ein
15 grad konformes wahlprogramm vorlegt
geschweige denn dass eigentlich alle
parteien einen 15 grad konformes
wahlprogramm vorlegen müssten damit man
eine ernsthafte wahl hat denn alle
parteien haben dass abgesehen von der
fdp haben das pariser klimaabkommen 2015
unterzeichnet und sich damit der
einhaltung der 15 grad grenze
verpflichtet und auch die grünen haben
ein parteiprogramm was nicht ausreicht
was an vielen stellen beispielsweise
sagten gas mal gucken ob wir da so
wirklich aussteigen autobahnprojekte
neue könnte man auch noch einmal
überprüfen und inmitten der klimakrise
bei einer globalen ehrt erhitzung von
1,2 grad noch darüber nachzudenken neue
fossile infrastruktur wie gas aufzubauen
oder auch neue autobahn aufzubauen wo
klar ist wo mehr straßen dania verkehrt
da mehr co2 emissionen
das ist absurd und das muss man auch den
grünen sagen erreicht das wahlprogramm
nicht aus bevor wir das zurückgeben
in die politische arena schnell zu dunja
auf die andere seite unserer
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer die das
vielleicht ein bisschen anders sehen
lukas hofft könnte ich mir vorstellen
sieht das ein bisschen anders schöner
abend unternehmer aus nürnberg
wenn sie das zu hören was kann es mir
gerade gesagt hat und was ja auch viele
andere fordern nicht nur jugendliche die
auf die straße gehen machen sie sich
dann sorge um die wirtschaft um die
arbeitsplätze und ähnliches definitiv
also wie gesagt ich habe ja auch ein
bisschen andere denke als die andere
seite gerade sag ich mal gegenüber auch
wie er es die mir schon gesagt es muss
jetzt gehandelt werden wir müssen jetzt
diese schritte einleiten so kann es
nicht weitergehen
dem will ich eigentlich widersprechen
weil diese schritte die wir jetzt gehen
müssen sie sind meiner meinung nach noch
nicht ausgereift sei es die elektro
automobil industrie woher kommen die
batterien wir sagen wollen in
deutschland damit anfangen da gebe ich
mir ein lindner meiner meinung nach
recht dass wir so ein kleiner fleck er
das sind und nicht nur auf deutschland
schauen sollten das ist ein globaler ist
sage ich mal kein klima nationalismus
sondern wir müssen global denken
klar müssen wir bei uns anfangen aber
wie gesagt mit den richtigen wegen und
die aktuellen wege die wir einschlagen
wollen zu meiner meinung nach falsch
also in vielen fällen sozusagen ein
bisschen konzepte und nationale lösung
ist ihn zu klein
das auf alle fälle also national muss
man anfangen auf alle fälle aber wie
gesagt der klimaschutz der endet nicht
an irgendwelchen landesgrenzen oder
etwas dergleichen sondern wie ein
bisschen global denken wir müssen in
deutschland anfangen klar aber wie
gesagt deutlich strukturiert war
sonst gehen wir im falschen weg den wir
am ende bereuen werden herr hofft bisher
vielen dank haben wir das natürlich
gleich mit hier in die mitte in die
arena ist eine perfekte frage für cem
özdemir deutschland immer nur alleine
bringt ja auch nix aber wenn ich da für
dich kurz noch darauf antworten also wir
wollen raus aus allen fossilen
energieträgern steht auch so im programm
drin und bei den autobahnen sind wir die
einzige in dem moratorium fordern
aber sie haben recht machen sie druck
auf uns aber bitte machen sie noch mehr
druck auf die anderen denn wir sind ja
die einzigen die das fordern sonst sieht
man halt allein ihr stark so stark wie
wir sind umso mehr kümmert durch sitzen
und zu dem was sie gesagt haben alles in
er
ich sage nicht deutschland ist der nabel
der welt aber schauen sie es doch ganz
einfach wenn wir sagen die anderen soll
es machen wir machen so weiter wird
niemand dem folgen
umgekehrt wird ein schuh draus wenn wir
hier zeigen wachstum wohlstand jobs und
klimaschutz geht es zusammen und wir
haben alles was es dafür braucht schauen
sie ich komme aus stuttgart bei uns ist
ein unternehmen das hat heute verkündet
werden wir hier sitzen das des
aufsteigers und fossilen verbrenner die
sind schneller wie die politik die haben
es endlich kapiert ich war dort der
genius sagt zu mir wir brauchen den co2
preis der chef von den anderen
unternehmen sagt aber die sagen alle
auch es wird nur funktionieren wenn wir
hier erfolgreich sind wenn man nachahmer
bekommen gute nachricht wir werden
absatzmärkte für die wirtschaft bekommen
wir müssen endlich dafür sorgen dass
wirst du sozialen eine ökologisch
soziale marktwirtschaft machen da bin
ich zuversichtlich aber die politik muss
ihren job machen einen rahmen der für
setzen und der fehlt bis jetzt und der
job der politik ist ja eigentlich auch
beiden seiten hier die angst zu nehmen
das haben wir ja gerade gehört ist auf
beiden seiten die sorge und die angst da
die einen sagen die transformation geht
zu schnell die anderen sagen geht nicht
zugeht nicht zu nicht schnell genug
herr lindner wollte nochmal nach karims
mal fragen wie können sie denn ihr die
angst nehmen als fdp chef dass sie die
richtigen maßnahmen treffen und wie das
mit der klimawandel schon schnell genug
und gut genug hinbekommen frau reemtsma
erkennt ja sehr gut die programme und
deshalb weiß hier die fdp hat im grunde
das härteste klimaschutzprogramm in
deutschland weil wir uns anders als
beispielsweise die kolleginnen und
kollegen der grünen nicht auf einzelne
maßnahmen verlassen
also eben in der aufzählung von cem
özdemir tauchten ja schon verschiedene
verbote und so weiter auf darauf
vertrauen wir nicht sondern wir haben
einen
ein vorschlag für einen harten co2
deckel so nennen wir dass das co2 das in
deutschland noch initiiert werden darf
im rahmen des budgets damit dass 1,5
grad ziel frauen zwar nicht verletzt
wird dieses budget wollen wir fixieren
mehr geht nicht
aber die verteilung lieber tempels zu
mir die wollen wir nicht in die hand
geben von politikern wie ihnen und mir
sondern da vertrauen wir auf den
marktwirtschaftlichen wettbewerb und auf
den erfindergeist unserer wirtschaft und
natürlich falsche entscheidungen darf
die politik trotzdem nicht treffen um
den kleinen ball den er mir zugespielt
hat zurückzuspielen also die fdp würde
anders als die grünen in baden
württemberg im jahr 2020 ein neues öl
kraftwerk nicht genehmigen
das haben ja die grünen in baden
württemberg gemacht ein öl kraftwerk das
schmutzigste was es gibt ausgerechnet
mit einem grünen ministerpräsidenten
beschlossen
davon rate ich ab aber wenn wir so einen
co2 deckel haben für deutschland
insgesamt
dann werden wir einen technologieschub
erleben ich mache einem einzigen
beispiel noch deutlich wie gestalten sie
dass eine einzige beispiel bald
schimmels denn jetzt zu recht sagt nicht
warten und passgenau dazu rwe und basf
haben jetzt das angebot gemacht sie
wollen vor der küste ein wasserstoff
windpark bauen um mit diesem wasserstoff
windpark wollen sie den größten
stromverbraucher deutschlands nämlich
den chemiepark ludwigshafen klimaneutral
machen und die haben nicht gefordert von
der politik verbote das einzige haben
auch nicht subventionen also geld
gefordert das einzige was die erbeten
haben sind schnelle planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren und dass die
politik die fläche in der nordsee nicht
erst nach dem jahr 2030 freigibt sondern
vorher in die ausschreibung gibt und die
branche müsste mir wenn das das ist was
ihr grüner auch wollt ja dann können wir
uns doch gemeinsam darauf verständigen
die planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
schnell zu machen für alle notwendige
infrastruktur und auch flächen in der
nordsee schneller freizugeben
auch in polen wo der wein der fdp mal
recht geben könnten
die emissionshandel den christian lind
nun die fdp möchte europäisch braucht
jahre bis er kommt die zeit haben wir
nicht und wenn er dann kommt der
emissionshandel
sagt vku verband der kommunalen
unternehmen sie kennen den da sitzen
auch fdp darin dass wir dann einen preis
hätten der durch die decke gehen würde
das heißt die klägerin alleinerziehende
wird sich dann das autofahren nicht
leisten können unser co2 steigt langsam
mit planungssicherheit
investitionssicherheit so dass alle
marktteilnehmer sich darauf einstellen
können und wir geben das geld zurück an
die konsumentinnen und konsumenten pro
kopf also schon mal sozial gerechter
klimawandel und soziale gerechtigkeit
müssen kein widerspruch sein im
gegenteil
und dann ist ihr problem doch folgendes
ihr problem ist wenn es das europäisch
machen herr lindner und die bulgaren die
rumänen beispielsweise co2 einsparen
sondern gehen ob die preise durch die
decke wenn das ihr argument ist wir
können sie dort die akzeptanz nicht wir
müssen ich sage es nochmals hier mit
gutem beispiel vorangehen wir haben
jetzt den usa eine administration beiden
die will klimaschutz die stellt gerade
massiv um gegen härteste kämpfer
die haben es viel schwieriger wie wir
weil wir zwei sind ja immerhin einig
dass wir den klimawandel nicht in frage
stellen dort stellt die hälfte in frage
und trotzdem machen einen ganz wichtigen
lassen sie uns kurz beim stichwort
emissionshandel ist kompliziert aber wir
haben ist das duell sein soll dachte ich
wir können auch ganz kurz auf lang
aussprechen zuschauern zuschauer wollen
noch mal ganz gut erklären kann muss man
einfach mal sagen wir reden hier über
emissionshandel über zertifikate über
summen und über tonnen und was weiß ich
und ich kann mir vorstellen zu hause
sind vielleicht auch der eine oder
andere denkt moment mal was ist also
eigentlich genau wie funktioniert das
worüber reden die da gerade und wasser
das war mit mir zu tun und was kann ich
tun
deswegen bin ich froh dass wir eine
unternehmerin bei uns haben nämlich gut
von heusinger
[Applaus]
erklären sie uns ganz kurz was es jetzt
damit auf sich hat und was sie dann auch
eben als unternehmerinnen machen also im
emissionshandel der europäische
funktioniert so dass die co2 emissionen
gedeckelt sind
das kann man sich so vorstellen als ob
zum beispiel im müll systemen die anzahl
der mülheimer begrenzt sind und man dann
rechte kaufen muss um halt eine
mülltonne zu bekommen und man kann ja
auch dem nachbarn dann weg kaufen und
der hat dann zb keine mülltonne mehr
muss irgendwie umstellen das halt kein
müll mehr produziert und genau das
machen wir mit der gemeinnützigen gmbh
die ich gegründet habe dass wir diese
emissionsrechte den kohlekraftwerken der
stahlindustrie wegkaufen so dass die die
nicht mehr nutzen können und wir haben
jetzt mit fotos abonnenten geschafft
dass wir halt 1500 emissionsrechte weg
gekauft haben
das sind 1500 tonnen co2 die nicht mehr
in der eu ausgeschlossen werden dürfen
und das ist so viel wie ein kleines
kohlekraftwerk das in einem tag und 9
stunden produziert also es müsste dann
für einen tag und 9 stunden abschalten
das heißt sie kaufen zertifikate auf die
kann kein anderer kaufen benutzen sie
nicht die welt aber weniger zertifikate
und die werden dann auch gleichzeitig
teurer natürlich für die eine seite
effekt genau erstmal gibt es weniger
zertifikate dadurch wird der markt
fucked up dadurch wird es teurer dadurch
kriegen die unternehmen rudern anreiz
klimafreundlicher zu produzieren und das
funktioniert auch bereits vattenfall hat
jetzt letztes jahr ein
steinkohlekraftwerk dass moorburg
stillgelegt und das wird jetzt teil des
hamburger green energy hubs und das ist
genau das was wir brauchen
wir müssen raus aus dem klimaschädlichen
aus der klimaschädlichen wirtschaft und
die klimafreundliche wirtschaft
vorantreiben und dafür ist er ja das
funktioniert mit dem emissionshandel
sehr gut wunderbar vielen dank das würde
ich jetzt gleich wieder gerne an herrn
lindner geben jetzt also herr lindner
da nutzt jemand den markt um dinge zu
verändern dann müssten sie doch als
fdp-chef sagen wunderbar passt wunderbar
passt denn das ist genau die idee die
wir haben das auch in deutschland
einzuführen nicht nur europäisch sondern
in deutschland in allen sektoren also
auch für den verkehr beispielsweise und
die landwirtschaft gegenwärtig ist dass
frau heusinger ja nur energie und
industrie ich selbst bin übrigens auch
dadurch einen vergnüglichen klimaneutral
weil ich jedes jahr meinen privaten co2
ausstoß auch löschen lassen jetzt nicht
bei ihnen sondern bei einem anderen
anbieter aber das system funktioniert
ist übrigens muss man sagen kein
ablasshandel
früher sagte man ja katholische kirche
und war sünden begangen und du zahlst
applaus und bist frei von sünde
heute würde man sagen du willst grün
bist du frei von sünde
[Musik]